i heard that you were you're doing this
promotional tour for jackass 3.5
and that it was almost interrupted the
tour was almost interrupted i thought
well gee did something bad happen
but i guess it was a what no it's jury
duty i get called in for jury duty
and and it was some case with the police
alleged
excessive force or something and you
have to go up and get in front of the
judge and they ask you questions
to see if you'll make a good jury member
yeah and i was trying to be as honest as
possible
and and she was like well have you ever
uh
dealt with police you know have they you
know i was like yeah a lot
and have you ever been attacked i'm like
sure and i got stabbed at my friend's
bachelor party
and is that true yeah yeah yeah
wait a minute uh okay how did you get
stabbed at your friend's bachelor party
well i promise i was minding my own
business trying to call a cab
and three guys drove by and yelled at me
so
i yelled back and the next thing i know
i have three guys in my face
wanting to fight and i have two guys
with me and i turn around and go
you guys have my back and they said no
and i was like oh here goes nothing and
so i hit the first guy
and and then i hit the second guy it's
the first time that i was actually doing
okay in a fight
right until i looked down we've been
fighting a couple minutes and my hand
was slashed and my back was slashed and
uh where did that come from there's that
he had a pin knife in his hand that i
didn't see
and so i had to go upstairs and get my
friends out of the bar we had another
drink and they drove me to the hospital
wait a minute i've been stabbed i've got
to get to the hospital but first another
drink
i had a tequila anesthesia
anesthesia yeah yeah but the hospital
was like a half mile away but they
made a succession of wrong right turns
and it took me
an hour and a half to get there
i love that you're laughing at this
story and i bled to death
the end well okay did you get on did you
get on a jury no
they threw you off i guess i wasn't a
credible juror no i guess not
well uh 10 years now it's hard to
believe 10 years doing jackass
yes and i know that you guys when when a
filmmaker
uh makes a film a director they sketch
out they make storyboards
for what they're going to do and i was
told that you do that
for jackass stunts is that true yeah
sometimes we'll uh
you know write out the ideas and
sometimes i'll i will sketch storyboards
to turn in
and i think uh we i think i may have
given you a couple
yeah i think the produce has we have
these uh there's they're okay
wait a minute that's i thought these
were gonna be more sophisticated no no
no no
i do that myself oh okay and and that
was a
giant snowball supposed to let's see
this oh yeah but
we couldn't build a snowball so that bit
was out the window wait so and uh so
you couldn't you forgot the stem on the
jack-o-lantern
that snowball looks like it has like
donald trump hair
that was supposed to mean movement oh
but i didn't know how to
convey movement okay wow these are
these are cave drawings well
let's see another one what's this next
one
oh my god this is woodpeckering and
that's chris pontius did this in treat
3.5 actually
we have woodpeckers flying around
a uh balsa woodpecker and
it it has to they have to peck through
the wood to get to the
you know oh wait a minute okay so that
the woodpeckers are attacking
a wood sheath around yeah okay
that's the idea and and just to be sure
that they would
they would attack we had to hide some
grubs under the wood sheathing
actually i had to hide the grubs under
the wood sheathing
okay it wasn't a good job no uh how did
that one work out
i forget uh what do you mean how did it
work out
it worked out great now i'm told that
you showed jackass 3d in it to a nursing
home when it was done
one of the first things you did is you
took it to a nursing home before other
people got to see it and screened it
there is that true
yeah we were doing promos for it and so
we took it to uh the old folks home
and and showed it to them and i was
really worried because it's it's naughty
you know there's a lot of ding ding in
the movie
and ringing of bells
[Laughter]
and we showed it to them and afterwards
the first note that came from the ladies
is they wanted more ding ding
and and yeah they liked it okay
that's fascinating to me they weren't
frightened by it or they loved it conan